addressing Bitcoin I published it a year
ago nearly and it's basically a really
easy guide to understanding Bitcoin it's
kind of for the people who want to know
about Bitcoin but they they feel
overwhelmed and intimidated by all the
major books out there so it's very
concise really easy language and it's
just like an amazing starting point to
learning about Bitcoin it's very up to
date with everything that's going on
even you know down to like El Salvador
it talks about the technicalities of the
Bitcoin Network how that works how it
hedge you against inflation and also
like politically why it's good so from
like a freedom downo it's on Amazon
there's a Kindle version there's an
audio version and yeah it's a super easy
read